you began making movies at three years
old i i would say three years old
yeah it was when i first started making
films so we had like a vhs
camcorder right and i was so inspired by
new zealand's funniest home videos
which was obviously the version of the
you know the bob saget america's
funniest home videos
so i would actually write and perform in
these
sketches that we would then submit to
new zealand's funniest home videos
so it might be like it's my birthday and
i would end up falling into the birthday
cake
or we'd be playing cricket and i'd get
hit in the nuts with a tennis ball
and i was like directing my family my
dad was operating the camera and i'd be
like you know make sure you get this
angle and
and that kind of thing and my sister and
my mum would would act in these sketches
so
that was technically my first directing
and acting yeah
what has been the longest time you've
ever taken a break from filmmaking
you know once i got going with it i just
haven't really stopped
yeah it's been pretty pretty relentless
i mean i got into it in my mid-teens
pretty hardcore and i've been going
ever since i've had to re-evaluate where
i'm at in my career along the way and
change
paths but i've never really stopped
i read in your bio that you suffered
from burnout
at one point yeah for sure you know i
mean what happened was i made these two
documentaries
they were one hour documentaries and
each one of them took four years
and i kind of did that on my own i
hadn't gone to
film school i had an amazing producer
named jonathan green who supported me
and we got funding and they they did
really well but
i just got to a point where i thought
man i've gone as far as i can
without some help and that was when i
decided to go to film school
which was in my mid-20s because i just
felt
it was time to get that expert feedback
it was time to really study and hone my
craft
i'd already started to find my voice but
i just needed to work on the technique a
bit
so that was kind of how i got out of the
the funk that i was in you know because
i was kind of depressed coming off my
second documentary
yeah i've heard that from other people
too because there is like this letdown
like it's finished it's out there and
then you don't know
how it's going to be received or also
the excitement of it is over
as well and just money i mean let's be
honest it all comes down to money and
financing these films often
uh it is tough financially along the way
we all know you can make a lot of money
in the film industry but we also know
it's not really at the front end you
know when you're starting out you're not
making a lot of money
so that's tough um
yeah you know and for me my second film
was really challenging i had some legal
issues with it
and i also documented family members in
my film
uh it was a film about new zealander's
obsession with rugby
okay so you might think well why is your
family in it well the reason is i
documented my relationship with my
father
because i realized that that was the key
to why i loved this
rugby team from new zealand the all
blacks that was it it was my
relationship with him
and i had some unresolved issues around
that relationship
so i decided to document that in the
film now my dad and i have never been so
close
you know we're awesome now but it was
tough at the time because
even though i was telling my truth in
the film that wasn't his
truth he didn't recognize the character
that was him that was in the documentary
so that was really tough because i went
into it with the best intentions you
know i'm going to make this truthful
documentary i'm going to tell my truth
well my truth
isn't my subject's truth and i kind of
had a breakdown about
god what is a documentary can you make
anything that's really truthful
i realized how subjective it is even
with the best intentions and i think
that was why i was ready to
smash that mold of documentary making on
this film used me that i've just made
because i just i didn't feel that a pure
documentary was a
kind of a form i even believed in
anymore to be completely honest with you
yeah yeah i've heard that uh dilemma
from other documentarians where
sometimes a film is never released just
because
the quote-unquote subject doesn't want
to be seen in a certain light
and even though it's kind of this raw
light um they want to have it to be a
certain way or
look a certain way or whatever 100 and
you know it's that whole thing it's like
you shoot 100 hours of footage
it's 3d it's in person it's the real
thing it's life
and then you see a movie and it's 2d and
100 hours is turned into one hour
and you're lying through omission you're
lying just by cutting things out or
choosing to emphasize certain things
and you are trying to craft it into an
emotionally satisfying story
now of course you're not trying to
mislead people but there is a sculpting
of that material i mean i'm
saying really obvious things here but
sometimes when the people you've
portrayed in the film see that
it is a rude awakening sure sure yeah
i've
definitely heard people that there's
just tons of footage and they can't
do anything with it yeah absolutely you
know and you try and communicate with
your subjects
but it is still your interpretation as
the director
and i don't know how truthful is
documentary it's still
it's still one person's point of view
even with the best intentions of being
honest
it's still that director shaping reality
into a story
what i find interesting is you have sort
of the opposite journey in that most
people go to film school
whether they become jaded or not and
feel it was helpful or not
then they go on to work or do things in
the industry or maybe they don't
but you had the opposite so did being in
class with other people who were excited
about movies
really ignite uh reignite the passion it
really did
it really did when i went to film school
it it kind of uh it sort of
jolted me back to life and kind of got
me out of the funk that i was in
um and it was interesting because i
studied directing
at the national film school in australia
which is called afters
australian film television radio school
and what was funny was um
it also reignited my love of acting
because i had wanted to act when i was a
kid i went to a performing arts high
school in australia i was acting two
hours a day that was part of the
syllabus
and then kind of moved away from that to
focus on directing but then i go to film
school
and our teacher samantha lang was taking
these acting classes and so we were up
acting for each other for a week and at
the end of it one of the directors said
to me you know i think
maybe acting is your calling and then
these other directors that i studied
with
started casting me in their films so
that was like
that was an amazing revelation for me um
and it that kind of got
me back in love with acting so yeah
being in that environment just
was so inspiring on so many levels
i understand your parents know a little
bit about photography or filmmaking
yeah no i mean my mom is an incredible
photographer
and she really um
you know she took me to movies i should
never have seen
like she took me to see deconstructing
harry when i was 11.
way too young um but it changed
my life i walked out of that thinking i
want to be a filmmaker
um you know previously my favorite movie
was independence day
with will smith which is a great
blockbuster don't get me wrong but once
i started seeing these
you know more adult movies and then i
get into hitchcock and then i get into
kubrick and
and soderbergh i was like okay
there are so many different ways you can
go with filmmaking and i was really
drawn to directors who explored
you know the messy sides of humanity and
how messy sexuality is and how messy
interpersonal relationships are and
how flawed we can be that kind of
ignited my love of storytelling even
more so uh yeah i do credit my mum with
really encouraging
me to become a filmmaker and you know
also my dad who's an incredible writer
and i'd like to think you know like some
some of that i got from him
too you know some of the writing skills
i hopefully possess
any tips they gave you or just like one
little piece of advice that always
stayed with you
yeah for sure you know i i think um
i started writing uh like books when i
was like
nine you know i just i was kind of
prolific now i don't know how good they
were but i was just prolific you know
and i'd show them to my parents and it
was super encouraging
and i do remember one thing my dad told
me which was
look you've just written this book you
know you're nine years old it's probably
not gonna get published
it's probably not gonna go anywhere just
being realistic however this is a great
achievement and it's a stepping stone
you've put your foot on a
on a stone and now take the next step
and then take the next step and then the
next
don't try and take a giant leap in one
go just keep putting one foot in front
of the other
and that has really guided my whole
career i would have to say just the next
step in front of me that's all i'm
really focused on
um and and that's how you get where
you're trying to go you know i i mean i
want to make big
studio movies in hollywood one day but
you know you don't get there in one step
so breaking it down into smaller steps
that's been really instrumental in
shaping my career
you mentioned previously your love for
acting and going to a performing arts
high school you've been in not one but
two
like viral ads or videos on youtube that
have received what
millions right of views how does that
happen
well you know my acting career kind of
got kick-started by studying directing
that's the irony because um the person
who directed
its time which is an advertisement
supporting marriage equality
was one of the directors i went to film
school with his name is stephen mcallen
so he saw me acting and then he kind of
got the idea to put me in this
short and it was produced by another guy
peter slee who i also went to film
school with
um and i got to tell you you know that
two-minute
piece it's time i mean yeah i think it's
had like almost 17 million views on
youtube
madonna shared it stephen fry um
oh my god i got my own float in the
mardi gras in sydney
literally you know in front of a million
people i was there on a float waving
like
how cool it was so cool it was so
surreal
and it was a political ad it was
basically supporting same-sex marriage
which was not legal
at the time in australia it is now
thankfully um
it's crazy to say this will probably
never happen again but it was crazy
being involved in something that
actually
did shape the way people voted you know
it possibly we would like i think had
some effect on
policy which is is a pretty crazy
situation to be in but
what i will say is um we had a positive
message
in that short it was all about love it
was all about equality
tolerance and um it really showed me the
power of short form content
on the internet because i spent years
making these documentaries
but once that little two-minute piece
came out in 24 hours my life was changed
people now wanted to hire me as an actor
people were interested in what i was
doing
it was like a game changer overnight so
it just goes to show sometimes a short
little piece of content if it hits
people in the heart
can open a lot of doors so when
uh stephen the director yeah uh
released it um he led i'm sure all of
you know
and then how soon after did like people
start emailing you
and i'm sure you were recognized yeah on
the street
so it was released by a company called
get up who are kind of this activist
organization uh in australia um you know
what it was pretty instant it was one of
those things it went viral i guess it
got to a million views
in a day or less wow so for me it was
instant it was being recognized in the
streets
it was people coming up to me you know
and like telling me
that they were um
you know like people said that they came
out of the closet you know because
they saw the ad like they hadn't told
their family
and the ad gave them the inspiration to
do that and made them feel like it was
okay
and that was the you know that's the
best praise i've ever got for anything
i've been involved with i'm sorry
you know i feel emotional because it
really connected with people and that
was like what we
hoped when we made it we hoped it would
touch people's hearts
and make people feel it was okay you
know just to be who they are so
hearing that back was the best part and
it was
it's the nicest thing that's ever
happened in my career honestly being a
part of that
yeah and how soon did it take for it to
get to the 17 million
that's fine you know it's just kept
creeping up and you know there's still
places in the world where obviously it's
not legal so
it's kind of been this evergreen piece
of content
and um yeah it continues to be seen
we're so proud of it
and uh yeah i still see it popping up i
still get recognized in the in the
streets for it to this day
so it's it's really been cool yeah i
hope people can
uh we'll put a link to it and great yeah
yeah yeah it's a great place to work
and steven mccallum did a great job
directing it michael ponton petersley
great producers
get up we're amazing great team yeah now
it's very heartwarming when you see it
and you don't totally know well i don't
want to give it away it's all right i i
recommend people check it out yeah then
you had a second one
go viral did you was it a second ad or
something you know i made a film about
depression called
all blacks don't cry and i i played my
childhood hero
john kerwin he was a famous world cup
winning all black and he almost lost his
life because of
his struggle with depression so i made a
short when i was a lot younger
about that and um you know again to
i guess i've been drawn to making
entertainment
that can change people's minds about
issues or do reflect the world that
we're in and do reflect social issues
that is something that
excites me now the most important thing
is to entertain people but if you can
make them think about an issue or maybe
change their mind
that's that's pretty cool too so then um
that one has over a million views or let
me see
you know what that one probably is only
around a hundred thousand
oh okay that's so good though yeah it's
been good it's been good and it's helped
people be very open about depression
which is
which is great you know because asking
for help is the first step
with depression you know and that's
something i've experienced myself
and it's something that you know trying
to be a filmmaker
if you have some underlying anxiety
it'll bring it out in you
because it is a hell of a challenge um
but the day that i asked for help
was when i started to get better and um
you know i haven't been depressed in a
very
long time because i put a lot of energy
into my mental health
yoga meditation um
i drink very little you know these are
all things that help me as a filmmaker
because i feel like i
you know i gotta i gotta be at my best
because it's a tough industry so looking
after myself
is how i've been able to have a career
with some longevity
yeah because there's so many
opportunities to become depressed with
doing this whether it's
you don't get a role or you something
falls through
it's it's so easy for little things to
happen and then
or you make a great film it's done it's
out there in the world and now what
and it's like who cares right it feels
like that it can't feel like that
um this game is all about perseverance
you know you have to be an energizer
bunny you just have to keep
going um but for me
i can see my whole career ahead in my
mind you know so i'm always
moving towards that it kind of pulls me
forward
that's fine for me but when you're
working with other people you have to
inspire them
too and i guess the thing i would say to
filmmakers who are trying to get funding
or
trying to get an audience trying to get
people to work with you
make it all about what they're going to
get out of it don't talk about what
you're going to get out of it because
it's obvious what you're going to get
out of it if you make a film that wins
awards or makes money
educate people about what they're gonna
get out of it
and that's something that's helped me
get financing get films made
and um that's been critical like i can
tell you a story about
you know when i went to um my high
school right when i was 17 years old or
and i wanted to make my first
documentary and i had to convince them
to let me work on it three days a week
so i'd miss school
for three days right i'd go to school
two days a week i'd work on the
documentary
i was so arrogant it's almost
embarrassing now but i said to them
this is a good thing for you because i'm
going to get
great results i promise you i'm going to
get between 95
and 100 for my final mark in high school
um but i'm going to make this film
that's going to be super successful it's
going to win awards it's going to go to
festivals it might take a while
but it's all going to happen okay and
when it does
you are going to be seen as so
avant-garde and that you really did
support the independence and
individuality of your students
which is what your school is meant to be
all about i said this to my principal
margaret markham i'm so embarrassed now
i was so cocky
but it worked and she even found five
thousand dollars and gave it to me
and she gave me that independent
learning contract so i could go to
school two days a week and work on my
first documentary
and i look back on that the reason she
did it is because i told her
what the school would get out of it in
the long run not me but the school
so that is my number one tip for
pitching and financing
tell your prospective financier what
they're gonna get out of it
that's great advice and then did you
have certain things you had to present
to her by a certain time
too absolutely you know and i had to get
great marks academically i mean i put
myself under a lot of pressure with my
arrogance
luckily it did all work out um i kept
them up to date
i told them how the production was going
and then eventually the film kind of
caught fire you know and it went to the
berlin international film festival it
won an audience award
um and so they were delighted
they were really delighted but it was
funny like everything i kind of said
would happen
did happen so again you know i'm not
you know positive thinking and all that
stuff can be a bit of a cliche but i do
believe in manifestation
i do believe as the director of a
project you have to hold in your mind
where it's going to go and then transmit
that belief to people
and i've been lucky you know i have an
amazing producer jonathan green from
australia who i've worked with
since i was 16. so i've had that one
person always backing me and believing
in me
and you know i would say if you're just
starting out as a filmmaker
you probably do need one person in your
corner so find a producer
who believes in your talent and will
support you and be tough on you
and make you work hard that relationship
will be critical
in making work over time i heard a term
this weekend which is purpose driven i'm
sure it's already out there and it's
just me who's late to the party on that
one but i get that sense about you that
you're very purpose driven
is that something that's the case or
that that does
resonate with me yeah i think i'm always
moving towards a goal i have to like
hold the dream
in my mind of where i'm trying to get to
and it's like you know i i had this
dream of making a movie in america which
was really hard i didn't have an
american visa i didn't have
financing um but
you hold that dream in your mind and you
move towards it the one thing you can't
control is how long things take
right you know people talk about the
secret they talk about manifestation
okay and people kind of are like well
come on that's a little bit airy fairy
i really believe in that i think that
you move towards
whatever is on your mind and i think
your your unconscious mind does take
over and kind of
steer the car but life gets in the way
reality gets in the way you don't know
how long things are going to take so
i've always tried to take the pressure
off myself
like my dream was i want to make a
feature film by 30. that was the thing i
was moving towards
and it's pretty much happened you know
give or take a year
but i learned to let go of the the
timing
and i was just like well i want to make
a good feature film
at some point rather than just being
this achievement that looks good
or something you know because that was
like maybe a little bit thinking about
status or ego
you know when i was a teenager or early
20s when i had that goal
i've kind of learned a little bit to let
go and say what will be will be things
will take as long as they take but just
keep moving towards where you want to go
that's how i live my life
also too independent film takes so much
longer than people think
totally you know i heard an interesting
statistic in australia seven years is
the average
for an independent film meaning from the
concept through to say
the first festival screening that's a
lot of time
that's a lot of time both my
documentaries took four years
um i guess i first had the idea for use
me
five years ago so it's it's pretty
normal
it's pretty normal and that was a thing
even doing a kickstarter
uh and getting people to invest in the
film you have to remember they they're
not in the film industry they don't know
how long things take they might think
that it's going to take three months
so my advice to anyone doing kickstarter
is always be communicative with the
people
who are investing in the film because
they probably will have no idea
how long it takes to make a movie right
what kind of hashtag were you using to
get
i was just curious what kind of hashtag
did we use
wow i can't even remember the one we're
using now is what is real
because film kind of blurs the line
between um
fact and fiction yeah what kind of
hashtag did we use
i'm not sure you know it was very image
driven i mean social media is so
image driven like literally individual
stills
not a lot of text it's a very visual
medium so i realized that pretty quickly
yeah i want to hear more about that
later because i know that's probably
a big portion of why people
you know donated because it is so
specific and very image
driven so yeah definitely want to hear
about that um i just want to
follow up with something though it
almost seems like your life has been
like a real life
almost famous oh my god that's so funny
you say that that's really cool do you
know that when i was 15
i started working for film inc magazine
as a film journalist
and i had a column called almost famous
oh you did
okay well i did not know that because
cameron crowe was a teenage journalist
for rolling stone
and so i met dolph kornitz this
incredible guy from filming a
publication you should know about
really australia's best in my opinion
film publication
now it's an online site but uh he kind
of said to me
you're a bit of a cameron crow and he
gave me my own column so there you go i
was interviewing people after school
that was my job i
you know i was 15 and i went and
interviewed anne hathaway
how cool in her hotel room you know and
i'm like this pimply
testosterone-filled kid my voice is
breaking hi ann
nice to meet you how are you i can't
believe i got that job carmen electra
jason biggs and then directors david
cronenberg
jim jarmusch so that was my first film
school being a film journalist
right between kind of the age of 15 and
25 that was my first film school
because i was watching all this stuff i
wouldn't have normally watched because
because i had to review it
so foreign films or weird obscure
documentaries
um genres i wouldn't be interested in
and that was important i think when
you're starting out you need to expand
your taste and kind of watch stuff that
you're not even that into just to know
what it is and what what constitutes
a movie you know it's a big spectrum and
you've got to expand your mind at some
point so
those were formative years writing for
filming yeah
any juicy story you can tell leaving out
names or identifying uh
no i got a funny story and i'm sure
she'd be happy for me to use her name so
again this is when i was like 18
right so i'm just full of testosterone
and i got to interview carmen electra
wow it's cool
so i go into her hotel suite and she's
there looking at this magazine and i was
kind of like you know
hi carmen i'm julian from filming no
response okay maybe she didn't hear me
so i got a bit closer i'm like
hi carmen i'm just here to do the
interview still doesn't respond i'm like
is she really rude or does she have
headphones in
no nothing then i get right up to her
i'm like hi i'm julian
would you like to do this interview and
then she shows me what she was looking
at
she's looking at fhm magazine and it's
like
top 50 top 50 hottest women this year
and she turns it round and it's a double
page spread
and it's her in a thong like a g banger
with a diamond
on her coccyx and she's like sponging up
this car
and she was like i only came third in
the top 50 list
what do you think of this picture
and i was genuinely speechless
i think it was a rhetorical question on
her part
i think my eyes were on stalks my 18
year old eyes but that was funny you
know that was super funny and an
interesting insight into how when you
get famous
you your body and your personality
becomes this product and this entity and
she was kind of studying it looking at
it like how will my audience look at it
so
it was interesting and she's actually
very intelligent person calm and electro
i know she
leads with sex or certainly did a lot
early in her career but we had a great
interview and
she was awesome wow that's fascinating
so were you able to compose yourself and
i did i took a deep breath
all right great shot common let's do the
interview
yeah crazy
have you made any money from the short
films a little bit yeah
so i made a short film called clearing
the air uh which had two terrific
australian
actors marcus graham and then also uh
rhys wakefield
excellent actor i went to high school
with him and you know
now he was just in season three of true
detective so his career
and holly was really taking off but you
know i saw him when he was like 14. i
was like okay i can see the talent i see
where you're going
i like to think i discovered him but um
it was funny you know that film we
actually sold to airlines
as kind of interstitial in-flight
entertainment so yeah we did get a bunch
of checks from
qantas wow the film was set at an
airport it's this father-son
kind of reunion set at sydney airport so
yeah i had to kind of put on the the
creative producer
hat and think well where could we sell
this you know
and this was really before people were
sharing films
online a lot you know because a lot of
people just throw their short film
on to youtube or vimeo but uh yeah i
mean there are ways to make money from
shorts
but realistically for me they were more
calling cards to help me get to making a
feature
how did you find distribution for that
my mom worked for qantas okay and i just
was
thinking out loud and she said why don't
you try and sell it to qantas
interesting there you go we reached out
cold calls
they took it because they liked the film
wow yeah airlines are great you know my
second documentary cup of dreams i
pretty much sold it to every airline in
the world that was how most people saw
it so that that's a
genuine revenue stream and just a great
way for people to see your movie i watch
stuff
always when i have you know the flight
from sydney to la i watch like four
movies in a row so
yeah if you can sell to an airline it's
a good way to reach people and so they
would play it in between like features
and things exactly
yeah they would play it on the tv in the
screen yeah after like the
you know the the safety briefing and
everything
and then before the movie yeah yeah how
much does money impact the decision
of what film you will make next or what
kind of film
how honest should i be well look it all
starts with the idea
right so
you know use me didn't have any big
stars in it it's very concept driven
right sex cells sure so it has that
going for it
uh and the world of femdom and bdsm does
have a built-in audience so it had those
things going for it plus it's high
concept
but let's be honest if you don't have
movie stars i think your budget is
capped at a certain
point so i would think that the way to
move into making bigger budget movies
is to attract stars i'm very realistic
about that and i would love to work with
movie stars and
get the best performance possible out of
them and and i think you have to make a
bunch of stuff without stars just to
show that you can direct
show that you can tell a story that's
what i was trying to do with use me
you know in a sense it's a calling card
so that maybe people who do have a
profile will look at that
and go okay he seems to know what he's
doing i'll take a chance on him
again it's the step-by-step thing this
is kind of part of my strategy
hard to get stars for your first movie
but if you're mixing it's high concept
that um you know gets your name out
there gets some runs on the board that
can open doors for the next film in the
next film
so then you're because i know there's
people that like
for their first film they're asking
people to like
you know donate money which is friends
and family and that's great but it's
huge
chunks of money which it seems kind of
foolish at that point
for a first feature so it sounds like
you're very realistic
i think so i mean i think i knew um
you know i mean you make shorts for
thousands of dollars um making a first
feature without stars i mean you
probably need to do it for
half a million or less i know some
people have done it for five thousand
dollars or ten thousand dollars
or a thousand dollars i've heard some
crazy numbers but if you're going to
have
crew and some cost and a bit of scale
maybe look up to that half million
dollar
mark and then you might potentially
recoup that and then your investor might
want to go again on your next film
but but for sure you know you do need to
scale it back like i used to write
scripts that were like
20 million dollar movies and you get to
a point especially after film school you
kind of get smartened up to the business
and you're like
well there's no way that's going to be
my first movie maybe that'll be my third
movie
but you do have to think a little bit
smaller in scale for your first movie
just actually get it made just get it
made
that's my advice yeah have you always
been very practical
i i think i weirdly have been you know
because i think to make it in this
business
you have to have this bizarre
combination of being like a dreamer
daydreaming all day um just unashamedly
being creative and however you want to
do that if you want to smoke a joint and
lay on your futon and just daydream
that is actually working that is the
definition of working as a writer
director letting your imagination run
wild
so you need all of that on the other
hand you do have to think about dollars
and cents
you do have to think about how likely
something is to recoup
you do have to think about okay what
kind of marketable elements
do i have in this film how am i going to
put butts in seats
so for me it's always going back and
forth between the two and somehow i am
lucky i've been able to do that and you
know what i really credit my sister
i actually it just occurred to me my
sister's a surgeon
right um so she went through medical
school and
done all the i mean it's been like a
15-year process
so practical so pragmatic
and i think i modeled myself on her a
little bit even though i'm in a crazy
non-linear industry
i kind of saw what she was doing and i
thought well i need to be that practical
i need to kind of approach it like she's
approaching it it's a job
i need to think about money i need to
think about how long things will take
i need to have the same kind of work
ethic that she has so
i i think it's probably yeah my sister
rework probably inspired me to be really
pragmatic even as i'm chasing these
crazy dreams
what's the most money you've ever raised
for one project
uh well you know i guess probably at
this point
around the half a million mark for the
film i've just made
you know i can't give you the exact
number it's in that ballpark though
yeah well i'll tell you what a great
thing with crowdfunding is
don't necessarily think about that money
being the whole part of money what
crowdfunding does
is it gives you a proof of concept it
illustrates
audience engagement and if you can
illustrate that
then you can go and ask people for more
money with much more confidence
like my producer jonathan green was
really adamant about doing a kickstarter
because he said hey you want to find out
if there's an audience for this movie
put it online you know do the
kickstarter and then you're going to
find out
it'll either get traction or it won't so
it was really brutal it was kind of like
a
you know baptism by fire and it was kind
of like oh this thing might not succeed
luckily it did and it exceeded its mark
but what it really did apart from giving
us some funds that we needed
was it gave our film a shot in the arm
it got 200 fans who loved the movie
and wanted to support it and wanted to
tweet about it
and share about it on instagram so it
gave us
traction it put us on the map and that
actually
gave my producer more confidence to
invest because he could see something
tangible
okay people are liking the movie so
you know i would say doing it just as a
proof of concept
is a great way to go and maybe lower
your amount a little bit
you know don't don't think that the
kickstarter money is the only thing
you'll ever get
if you have a successful crowdfunding
campaign that confidence
becomes contagious so that would be my
advice to anyone trying to crowdfund
make sure you
have a win you know make sure you get
that target
so maybe lower maybe lower the amount a
little bit and blow through it that
would be my advice
yeah i think we were aiming for about 20
000 us
uh so we set it as about 25 000
australian and i think we got about 30
000 australian
so yeah it did it did go over and you
need that little buffer just
because people can still pull out so you
do need a little bit of a buffer
and i got to tell you it was hard work
it was a full-time job for a month
and sierra lynch is a genius at social
media but even then
it's it's and frankly she's a financial
dominatrix so
people have a fit one of my friends said
as if this crowdfunding isn't gonna work
you have a financial dominatrix and i
said okay i take your point
on the other hand they're used to paying
her
for this kind of sexual role-play thing
it's actually a different proposition to
say hey come and invest in an indie film
so we had to really educate her fan base
about no this is a completely different
thing
it's a movie it's a real thing this is
what you get for investing
and she had to put a lot of effort to
convert them because it wasn't the usual
it wasn't the usual transaction they
were used to it was actually something
different
so it was all hands on deck for a month
a lot of sleepless nights
and uh thrilled that we got there in the
end
i'll try to include the link to the
kickstarter campaign page because
you did a great job in creating this
intrigue and mystery even if
dom humiliation all that isn't someone's
forte
i thought you did a great job in terms
of creating a story out of the trailer
thank you and look that was the critical
thing that my producer jonathan green
said he's like okay we know that
people who are already into this kind of
thing or this strange sort of sexual
subculture
we know that they're already invested
his challenge to me was
try and get the most mainstream audience
you can try and get people who have no
interest in that world to bite on this
and we actually did that and that's what
gave him confidence
people who maybe not even have no
interest in fem dom and bdsm they might
even have an aversion to it
but they were pulled in because they
thought well actually this is a thriller
this is going to be an exciting movie
and there's some thought that's been put
into it there's a story here
um so so that was really the challenge
for us to reach a more mainstream
audience and now that's our challenge
with the film
being released you know we have to break
out beyond the niche the niche is only
so big
and i think we have a film that can do
that fingers crossed
and so when you raised the 30 000 uh
on kickstarter it was under the name of
ruin me and it was supposed to be a
documentary
well it's funny you say that i actually
never
called it a documentary i was setting up
the blurring of the lines
even back then three years ago on the
kickstarter now it did say from
documentary filmmaker julian shaw
which was true because i had only made
documentaries till that point
but i was very careful to include in the
trailer if you go back and look my
character actually says the words
this is not a documentary i made sure i
put that in there so that no one could
ever have any qualms
about the fact that the film is
fictionalized so
i think we tried to be transparent right
from the beginning
but it was funny even up until this
point i have friends saying hey how's
the doco going
and i'm like you know it's not a
documentary you know i was writing a
script for it
but people see what they want to see so
that's been very interesting
very interesting people have
expectations and you can be transparent
but people hear what they want to hear
so then you were able to get uh
producers on board before you did the
kickstarter obviously
you know i had uh one producer uh
jonathan green from australia uh who was
really supporting from the beginning
but he was a little bit you know careful
he he's never given me a cent that he
wasn't sure about put it that way
he he made me develop it in stages so
firstly we made a short film which will
never be released
it wasn't very good but it was a short
film to prove that i could act that
sierra could act
and that this kind of hybrid form was
actually engaging so he made this 20
minutes short
and he liked it he said okay you made
that now i feel a bit better about
investing in a feature
but let's make sure that there's an
audience for it so do a kickstarter
we did that big success then he said
okay now i'm comfortable to really
invest some more funds in this so he was
very smart it was a
a torturously slow process from my
perspective
but that development was needed and each
little milestone we cleared again step
by step
gave us all more confidence
is your goal to be a hollywood director
directing hollywood movies
yeah yeah it absolutely is
that's always been the goal and to do it
in my own
style i mean i'm in new zealander
originally right so i look at taika
waititi who directed thor
ragnarok you can't get much more
hollywood than that
it's a marvel studio movie hundreds of
millions of dollars
but he found his voice he found his
voice making these short films and then
these
small independent features in new
zealand and you can see that voice
in thor ragnarok now it's also hugely
commercial it's got
movie stars it's a marvel cinematic
universe movie so it's
about as marketable as it gets but the
essence of his voice is in that movie so
i look at someone like that and i go
hell yeah that's a great thing to aim
for you know
so this has been a journey of me finding
my voice and now i kind of
feel i'm finally kind of grabbing it and
kind of have it in my hands and own it
and i think for sure my goal is to make
movies on the biggest scale possible
with great cast who are recognizable
and with amazing crew who are the top of
their game
if that's not your goal why do you want
to be a filmmaker you know
well just to play a devil's advocate it
seems like you are attracted to stuff
that's a little more edgy
and maybe taboo which i think is great
to want to
venture to places where most people be
squeamish um
and maybe i'm i'm projecting that onto
you and that's not really who you are
but
if you do want to do that you think you
can do that in a hollywood space
i think so i think so for sure i
understand my first film is
pretty edgy you know and has some pretty
taboo subject matter
but even within that i think people are
surprised that there is an emotional
arc to it you know and there is a
storyline
that does play to a mainstream audience
so yeah i'm drawn to
extreme characters and crazy worlds but
hopefully through this film i'm also
demonstrating
what i can do as a storyteller and i
think i could apply those skills to
more mainstream fair i'm very confident
i could actually yeah
because i've known other filmmakers who
have covered similar topics or different
things and they say
they have no interest in pandering to
independent film audiences or maine and
they
they just want to make films that they
want to make and cover interesting
subjects i know
it's a dilemma because sometimes you
feel like you have to do things that are
more
cookie cutter and mainstream to be able
to please everybody
i understand that yeah well it's a
balancing act isn't it because you don't
want no one to watch your film
and you do have to keep the audience in
mind but you also have to be drawn to
subject matter that appeals to you
particularly if you're going to spend
years working on something you have to
be
excited by it but i guess what i'm
excited by
is taking the audience on an emotional
journey
i mean that's the only thing all my
films kind of have in common
so that's the process and in a funny way
the subject matter
the themes that can change but
i mean you're there to tell a story
you're there to engage people you're
there to take them on this emotional
rollercoaster ride
and you know as you're making shorts and
then documentaries and now my first
feature you're going through a process
of honing
that skill set to be able to do that so
you know i think i'm really open to
whatever the next story is i don't have
it totally in mind yet
but um i'm just drawn to provocative
subject matter that doesn't have to mean
it's controversial or niche or edgy or
offensive
but something that first elicits that
emotional response from me
and then i work out okay well how do i
translate that to an audience and that's
kind of the
that's the that's the art that's what
this whole thing is super hard to do
but that's the challenge
what's your pre-production checklist
you know i don't storyboard a lot uh
certainly
having a shot list i mean certainly
speaking to every head of department
well in advance
and i gotta say if you're acting in it
and you're the director you've got to do
twice as much work
because you kind of need to make sure
that there are people
who will be honest with you about
whether you're getting what you need
for the edit room because it doesn't
matter if it's you right
at the end of the day you're going to be
in an edit suite six months or two years
down the line and you're going to be
watching your leading man and if he
hasn't given you enough material to work
with you're gonna hate him
even if it's you so what i had to do
really was
tell my um you know my unit production
manager tell my
uh my cinematographer tell all the heads
of department
pretty much this is what i need from my
performance
and i'm going to be so caught up
answering a million questions but just
make sure i'm doing
what i said i was going to do and you
know writing it down on a piece of paper
so we're very clear i need to have these
beats
because i'm going to be in the edit
suite later and i'm going to hate myself
if i didn't do it
so that's just an extra complication if
you're performing in it
um but you know i think the best advice
is that you do a lot of your directing
beforehand you go in there and you've
got it all kind of mapped out it's going
to change on the day and sometimes those
are the best accidents but the more you
can do to prepare
the more free you are on the day to play
that's what i've found
yeah so you invited them to be tough on
you essentially oh yeah wow that's
really cool yeah
you know and you got to be honest you
know sometimes i do a pretty bad take
you know
or i'd be in the edit suite and i think
yeah just you know
let's just be honest it's not working so
if you can't have that kind of candor
you shouldn't
you shouldn't act in your own film
because you're inviting criticism by
doing that
um so yeah honesty from the beginning
super important
really important but i looked at a lot
of you know um
directors who had directed themselves
like ben affleck who has done it
brilliantly
he had a really good point which was
that
when you're on set you're not actually
self-indulgent you actually go into this
sort of
faux modesty which is let's get all the
other people's coverage first and let's
really get
you know say sierra the the female lead
in the film you know let me really make
sure i've got her performance let me
spend all my time on that
and then you know time's getting short
and you're like oh well let's just
quickly do my take let's just do one or
two and just bang it out
and and he just had this great point he
was like no
don't be false modest don't be like oh i
just need one take just quickly do it
like
if you need five takes do it
because eventually you're gonna be in
the edit suite looking at yourself
and you're gonna be angry if you didn't
have enough coverage and didn't give
yourself enough options so treat
yourself like any actor make sure you
get what you need
so you have to compartmentalize it's a
pretty crazy thing when you're acting in
it too but
you have to be able to compartmentalize
and just see hey this is an actor who
happens to be me
giving me the raw materials i need for
the edit so
it's tough it is tough because you also
played julian
another version of julian sort of that's
right
in the film yeah and sierra plays
herself so our performances are always
kind of walking the line
between who we really are and who these
characters are so it was a bit of a head
trip so
being very open and communicative with
everyone was it was important
and what kind of notes would they give
you when they wanted another take from
you
just blunt like hey let's do that again
or what would they say
yeah for sure you know um my my producer
on set aj gordon would just be like hey
man i'm not sure if i was feeling that
one
were you in that and i'd be like yeah
maybe not maybe i was at 90
let's try and get to 100. so just that
kind of shorthand not about being
critical
but um you know also just just making
sure you have coverage just the
practicality
of it you know even when you're shooting
in a documentary style and it's quite
verite and quite kinetic and raw
you still have to make sure you've got
all those elements you're going to need
in the edit suite so
i think the more experienced you get the
more you're able to backtrack from the
edit suite
where you know you're eventually going
to end up so you know you can project
into that space and think okay what raw
materials
do i need and kind of work back from
there
what is use me usually is my first
feature film
it is a thriller and it's a film
that blurs the line between fantasy and
reality
right from the very first frame it
started as a documentary about sierra
lynch who's a world famous
online humiliatrix which basically means
she
is well paid by men to verbally abuse
them
and take large sums of money from them
and
fantasy role play blackmailing them
crazy stuff but they they love it so
uh in the film i play myself a
documentary maker doing a film
about sierra lynch trying to find out
who the real sierra is
i develop some feelings for her i
uncover some aspects
of her work that she was trying to hide
from me and things
go deliciously awry
that's used me so it had
several sort of evolutions to it i know
it had a different title which we can
get into later but
it started out as one thing or it always
was that one thing
no i mean look so you know i just
thought
this person sierra lynch is a great
subject for a documentary
and i wrote to her and i said i'd love
to meet you and film some stuff and see
if there could be a documentary project
in this and she luckily knew who i was
because she'd seen its time that
marriage equality show we were talking
about
so that gave me a bit of cut through
because obviously she's got men sliding
into her dms all day every day
so luckily i got some traction there and
she was like come to portland let's meet
so we did that filmed her for a few days
and it went awesome
it went really well she was everything i
hoped for and
more i mean she was incredible but i
also just had this nagging feeling like
i don't really see a documentary in this
because honestly she was super well
adjusted
super hard working happy person down to
earth
what's the story you know so i actually
realized that there was some murky
aspects of what she did
that i really wanted to explore in a
fictionalized story
and that idea came pretty pretty early
and um it kind of developed from there
and she she was down for a film that
kind of
busted through that genre line of
documentary and
played in a more narrative space while
still incorporating elements of reality
she was really down for that she
loved that concept so it became a real
uh
amazing collaboration over the last few
years yeah
did you actually write out a script with
like a
three-act structure totally totally
wrote a 90-page screenplay
my producer jonathan insisted and i said
to him look but there's going to be a
lot of improv and this and that and he
was like i get it
i get what you're making but write a
hollywood
formatted standard 90 page screenplay
first
which was grueling but it was a good
exercise because that was kind of the
platform
upon which we could improvise or we
could tweak the story or take it in a
different direction
so you know i would say to anyone who
thinks they want to make a fully
improvised feature
i mean do write as much as you can
because eventually you have to write it
like i remember the last scene in the
film in my script that just said like
improv and then i had a few notes so
then you get to the day where you're
shooting the last scene and you're like
oh
great all i did was defer writing it
like now i have to write it under
pressure and we're losing light and i
need another coffee and we've got one
hour to shoot this scene
why didn't i just write it before you
know so
it is dangerous to rely on improv i
think you do need that solid foundation
get that stand on that and then you're
actually free to go
wherever you want to go that's really
been my learning the more prepared you
are
the more flexible you are it's kind of
ironic but that's that's kind of my
biggest lesson
yeah forgive me if this is too personal
but your ex-girlfriend
is in the film she is yeah yeah sarah
armanius
amazing actor you know i went out with
her for 10 years
and uh yeah we i had started making this
film while we were breaking up
oh yeah yeah and um
you know we had a conversation about it
about the film and about how maybe
there's going to be a storyline
you know involving this character's
girlfriend
and he's gone through a breakup and
maybe because she's an actor she's a
creative person she was like
okay well maybe we should incorporate
this if this whole thing is about
art imitating life then let's use that
so there are actually scenes from our
real
breakup that are in the movie you know
she gave full consent she knew it would
be in a
fictionalized film but yeah it's pretty
it's pretty raw it's pretty it's pretty
real and i think the audience can
feel that you know it's kind of
uncomfortable to watch but um
yeah she was she was down for it and i'm
grateful she's a terrific actor she
wasn't an actor i don't think she could
have
done that and had the camera going on
while we were going through this crazy
you know
breakup but uh yeah uh
she's great she's a great actor and you
had seen
uh sarah on the joe rogan podcast or you
found out about her work
other ways that was subsequently you
know i discovered her
online accidentally i'll lift your
imagination how i decided
okay okay just just went down a rabbit
hole and
totally here i am no totally it was on
youtube okay it wasn't on pornhub or
anything it was i discovered her on
youtube i don't know how i got there i
mean i really don't
i shudder to think how i got there but
what happened was then i went to her
website
and of course she's a very attractive
woman and very sexy okay
but just because someone's sexy doesn't
mean that you think you're gonna build a
film around them
what it was was her website and this
blog that she wrote
she was just so intelligent and and
there was this design
to the whole sierra lynch character and
there was this
extraordinary command of social media
and
this blurring of the line between
fantasy and reality
and i was just intrigued i was like this
person is quite
brilliant and then i learned about these
fetishes i'd never heard of like
financial domination which is
kind of important in the film again
where it's a fetish when men
get turned on by giving vast amounts of
money
to a woman and getting nothing back
that's a turn-on
luckily i don't have that particular
fetish you just get married i mean
this is what people say i've had a few
people say you know i think my wife is a
mental humiliatrix
okay but uh you know i i just i really
was fascinated by
sierra and um again the interplay of the
persona with reality
the blurred lines it was all there right
from the beginning just from going on a
website
and i made a film that i guess reflected
that fascination that i had with her
yeah and sorry again if this is too
personal we can stop if it is but you
did develop real feelings for sierra i'm
not sure that i would
go that far but you know i think that
the pleasure of this movie is that
people can watch it and interpret it
however they like
and they can hopefully they just get
caught up and emotionally engaged in the
story that's the main thing
because when they do that what i keep
hearing is we don't really care what's
real and what's not we just like the
story and we just cared about the
characters however if you do like that
more meta aspect
people are having a lot of fun picking
what's real
what's fiction what's fiction very
closely inspired by reality
you know what's thinly veiled reality
people people have fun with that
so i'm more putting this out there i
don't necessarily want to comment on
exactly
where the line gets blurred but people
are enjoying figuring that out for
themselves so i don't want to ruin their
fun
well you said previously that you just
want to tell a great story it doesn't
matter really whether it's edgy or not
but why why this story why does it
intrigue you so
well you know it wasn't the sex i mean
it really
wasn't and that became apparent to me
after three days of working on what i
thought was a documentary
because the whole thing runs out of
steam yes it's fascinating hearing about
these fetishes
yes it's titillating and sexy and then
what
i mean you watch that for 15 minutes and
as an audience you're like okay
now what sure and that was kind of where
i got to
so why this story
you know i liked it because it let me
explore some deeper
themes about addiction
about narcissism and this world that we
live in now which i'm
guilty of which is selfie culture and
turning yourself into a brand and you
know especially in our line of work
where you have to have a social
media presence we all do that it's
performative and we use the raw
materials of our life to make a story
that's kind of fake and then put it out
there for the world to see so
i was just fascinated by where the world
has been
going and the narcissism in our culture
and also saying hey i'm a part of that
you know so it allowed me to explore
that um and then even ideas of what the
american dream is
right i mean sierra she sold her
excrement
for four thousand dollars oh wow okay
and in the film her lawyer her real
lawyer he says
she's living the american dream
yeah so that's the american dream
i need to dig a bit deeper into what the
american dream means so i kind of did
that in the film
so it allowed me to explore a lot of
issues i was really interested in
exploring
yeah i think i heard you say in another
interview
you know we live in a fake world which i
fully agree with but do you think now in
this current age that audiences are
craving authenticity or story
oh good question
great question story or authenticity i
mean ideally
both and
i think people are craving anything real
because everything is fake
i don't mean fake news i don't mean that
well worn
phrase that the president uses i mean
literally instagram where everyone is
face tuning themselves and photoshopping
themselves and
everyone is presenting this curated
highlight reel
of their life which i am guilty of too
because i just want to put positivity
out of the world so of course i show
me being in love or me working on a film
or me doing a cool interview with film
courage so
you are getting all the highlights and
that can be kind of exhausting
for people so
i i think there is a craving for people
to
see the warts and all reality of life
and i think i got to do that a bit in
this film
and i think as well you know it is a
fictionalized story
in this movie so it is kind of
artificial and yet there's authenticity
sprinkled
through that i'm really drawn to that as
a form
like i'm gonna be completely honest and
just out myself i'm a professional
wrestling fan
people are always gobsmacked i've loved
it since i was five
and for the record i realized it was a
scripted show when i was seven
okay and that was when i fell in love
with it more because i was like oh okay
so it's not an athletic contest it's a
show
it's performance art it's a circus okay
i love that and you know i use that as
an example because that's the most
obviously
assats artificial kind of storytelling
there is and yet there's authenticity
within that fake framework right it's no
coincidence that the rock dwayne johnson
is the biggest star in the world
how did that happen he had this
wrestling persona that he imbued with
his true personality
he invested his authentic self in this
silly wrestling character
and it caught fire and now he's the most
profitable actor on earth for a reason
because there's authenticity in that
fake framework if you get what i mean
and that's kind of like use me maybe
it's a longbow to compare it to
wrestling but
we're upfront about the artificiality
and use me we're up front that this is a
movie
this has a scripted narrative but within
that
there is truth within that there is
authenticity and i have to tell you
this is a much more honest movie than it
would have been if i made a pure
documentary
much more honest i could go so much
deeper into this world
i could go so much deeper into these
themes of addiction sexual addiction
technological addiction because i
fictionalized it
it was the lie that let me tell the
truth
and that's why i did it that's great i
like that by the way did you see
fighting with my family
i haven't seen it yet oh it's excellent
i would love to and and that was based
off a documentary i think
and so but but within that there is
there's the character of page
but then there's like this story that it
was about her family and different
things that she's gone through and so
yeah it is wrestling is interesting it's
very you know because
everybody's made up and they're whether
they've been tanning or you know and
their
hairs teased and stuff and there's a
supposed uh
fights and everything these these
long-standing animosities
right uh so it's easy to fall into that
but yes we we want to be it's just the
same thing you
you you see these women in the magazines
or on whatever you want to think that
there's a fantasy a story behind it you
don't want to know
some of the real things that they've
gone through that's right that's why
you're going there so escape reality
absolutely
but it's interesting on the wrestling
thing like wrestling is such a meta
thing
because people just get turned off
because they say yes the good guy versus
bad guy storyline
but i can see beyond that artifice and
i'm actually watching the performers
it's just like when you go to a movie
right and you're like okay it's meryl
streep playing this character like
you're emotionally connected to the
actor not just the character it's the
same with wrestling
it's real people who you're emotionally
connected to portraying these characters
and sometimes the story can be very thin
i mean let's be honest but
you're drawn to that spark and that
authenticity and it's why we get
obsessed with
actors it's why we get obsessed with
athletes we just we want that
authenticity we want that emotional
connection
so it's like it's all kind of meta it's
all kind of meta isn't it it's always
different
levels right it's like when you're
watching a movie you know it's a movie
yeah i don't know how wrestling is any
different sure yeah we want to we want
to escape ourselves
right and watch somebody else's dilemmas
exactly
yeah and and put yourself in their shoes
yeah at what point were you told by your
producer that you needed a script
did you already have footage with sierra
yep i already had footage with her
i'd shot some documentary stuff and then
just some raw stuff of us kind of
filming each other
and just exploring where the movie could
go
so there was a bit of a general sense
but my producer was just like you have
to write
a script you have to give me a 90 page
script and it was a brutal
process i mean i've written scripts
before but
never for something that is inspired by
reality
and that was really tough like
reconciling this
documentary footage and the reality of
her world
with a fictionalized storyline and
trying to keep the fictionalized
storyline
authentic feeling and still connected to
the reality
so it was a torturous process i like to
write in shitty motels
oh wow i did a lot of road trips and
would stay in
you know kind of like bates motel level
places i don't know why i can just think
straight when i do that
uh and you know a lot of riding just
happened walking on the beach
you know very early on i went to jarvis
bay in australia i smoked a joint
and started asking questions why does
anyone want to be ruined
what are people really wanting from
their interaction with her
is she a therapist does she heal people
in some ways these guys seem to be
you know so enamored with her like she's
a goddess or or
you know a healer like people said crazy
things about her you know in terms of
the influence that she had on their life
much beyond getting off but actually had
made them a better person
so just asking all these questions
allowed talking into my iphone recorder
that was how i started
finding okay what are the themes i
really want to explore
so you know it's not just about sitting
there writing on your laptop it's for me
it's a lot of voice recorder stuff
that's kind of how i do a lot of my
processing of ideas
i'm just wondering were a lot of these
men men that were in charge and so it
kind of felt good to reverse roles or
i'm just
assuming that no for sure there is that
and it's such a misnomer when you say a
submissive
male because you meet these guys and
they're high-powered
ceos now that's a bit of a cliche i'm
not saying everyone is like a judge or a
millionaire or something
but my take on human sexuality is it's
very compartmentalized if you have one
of these fetishes
it's because you probably were exposed
to something at a young age and
something just got hardwired in your
brain
to me that doesn't have a lot to do with
who you are in day-to-day life they can
be
very separate and i really found that a
lot
you know and some people like oh these
guys seem so normal when you meet them
i already had made that cognitive jump i
was like well of course
they're just people they just happen to
get off on this thing that you find
strange
and it's almost a coincidence that they
get off on that you know it doesn't
define
who they are but the film definitely
looks at
what happens if you bring a fantasy into
reality and the dangers of that because
sometimes it's better to keep your
fantasies in a little box
we all want our fantasies to come true i
would say this film explores a little
bit
well what happens if that fantasy comes
into reality what happens if you live
your fantasy
maybe you should be careful what you
wish for
and you went to a lot of conventions
with her or did and you
got to see like meet and greets oh yeah
i met all the women doing this line of
work
amazing people great friends of mine now
oh i got really deep
i got really deep into it i went to the
adult film expo a few times
in las vegas and and uh man
i mean again talk about blurring the
line between fantasy and reality
there's a giant party in the film
and we threw a real mansion party
in las vegas with real porn stars and
people attending and clients and
it was like we were shooting these
scripted scenes in a real
party atmosphere so that was a crazy
experience um but again it kind of
reflected in the footage it's got this
gritty
authentic kind of feeling so i was
always trying to tap into that reality
where possible even if it's a scripted
storyline but this
kind of bedrock of reality it's funny
borat
was a great inspiration for me you know
the sasha barrow yes
just the methodology again that's a
comedy completely different tone
but you know using reality as the
foundation for this fictional storyline
that did it very effectively and that
inspired me a lot yeah so you originally
had the name
you excuse me you originally had the
name ruin me
right and then at what point did you
find out there was another film with
that name
you know i would think in 2017 we became
aware that there was an independent
american horror movie called ruin me
and i was in denial for a while i was
like that's okay
there's just going to be two movies
called ruin me no problem
we all love the title ruin me um but
then you get to a point where you're
just like
you know it's not gonna work because
people go to google ruin me and their
film comes up instead of yours or people
start buying
the wrong thing on itunes once it's
available so you know we just spoke to
enough distributors and
and some friends who were sales agents
or you know people in marketing and they
were like
you need your own identity have your own
digital footprint don't confuse
yourself in the marketplace so it was
tough but we we made the change
and now i prefer the title use me i
really do because
addiction is quite a central theme in
the movie so
the word use using that concept
that kind of makes sense for this movie
yeah and both parties are using one
another
you know yeah and who's using who right
all that kind of thing sure
so yeah look i mean um i i wanna
i haven't seen the horror movie ruin me
i heard it's quite good and you know i
wish those guys all the best it's just a
shame it i mean i think it was just a
it was just a coincidence it happened
sometimes you both come up with the same
title at the same time they got theirs
out first so we kind of had to say all
right you have it and
we'll change the name any tips for
filmmakers that have
are saying okay i need to change the
name and we're already like picture
locked or whatever
any tips for them boy it's tough i mean
we had a four-page
document
i would just say figure out the essence
of your original title
so we looked at it okay ruin me
you'd think that the word ruin is the
key
aspect of it so we looked at ruined as a
title but it just wasn't as active
then we came to realize that actually
the me was the word
that command do something to me that
sense of a transaction
so we got rid of the word ruin and then
we thought well what else can be done
okay use me yeah you know
mutually using each other and it kind of
begs a question of yeah who is using who
so i guess figure out what the essence
of your title is and there's usually
another way you can express that yeah
and then
how many places did you have to then go
i mean i'm sure on imdb you had to go
and change it and
totally yeah it's a bit of a logistical
nightmare but
better to do it while you're still in
production and the film hasn't been
released than later
you don't want to change it after you've
released it so my advice is if there's
any confusion in the marketplace
better just bite the bullet and and just
change your title
and if it's a good movie i mean titles
are super important don't get me wrong
but if it's a good movie it's still
going to be a good movie no matter what
you call it
sure yeah and you updated your uh
kickstarter backers
yeah absolutely they were transparent
about the whole process and
and you know they were attached to the
title ruse that ruined me
but now they they love the title used me
so
it's great yeah and where most of these
uh backers excuse me
i guess maybe you answered this
previously but were they fans of sierra
or they were just in that space whether
they were
consumers of that type of material or
actually 50 50. you know um obviously
she's got
a fan base who are going to follow her
and support
projects that she wants to do creatively
and then people who are into bdsm or
femdom
but at least 50 percent of people who
have no interest in that world
maybe they like films that i've done
before maybe they just like thrillers
you know we we did manage to tap into an
audience who was
a little bit more mainstream and that
was great that was actually what gave us
a real
shot in the arm and made us saying okay
this film hopefully can
can break out a little bit you know we
don't want to just preach the converted
we want to find you know a wide audience
for this film so that was encouraging
what do you want from the characters in
your movie whether it's
narrative whether it's documentary
whether it's a blurred line
it's a cliche but you you do want an arc
i mean you want transformation
um that's critical you want to start
somewhere and end up somewhere else
that's how you elicit emotion from the
audience
frankly that's what inspires you as a
filmmaker to keep going you know that
you are telling a story like that
um that can touch people because we're
all inspired by
change and transformation so that's
that's kind of number one if i had to
boil it down and
meaningful non-cliched transformation
that's always
the goal you know um because there is
the kind of hollywood screenwriting 101
right where you know there's this
character arc and they change because
you know it's like how do you find a
fresh
spin on that and how do you maybe find a
new
dilemma that the audience hasn't seen
before how do you find a new challenge
so
this film kind of deals with i guess
technology addiction if i can say that
and and some stuff that i haven't seen a
lot of
films explore so that was inspiring for
us we kind of felt like we were onto
something sort of
novel here and that kind of inspired us
to push on and keep going
yeah you had an editor right yes i'm
sorry who just won
best editor at the brooklyn film
festival awards
ash watson terrific editor yeah oh
congratulations yeah
when when you and ash got into the edit
room together
um how was it to see the footage and
then the rough cut
did you feel that there was enough of an
arc well i kind of did my own rough cut
of the film
which was not great and you know i'm not
really an editor by trade so i worked my
ass off to make something not very good
and i was very depressed
by the first cut however it was the
proverbial lump of clay that
ash could then shape because if i just
given him 100 hours of footage
the whole thing would have taken a lot
longer and we really only had 10 weeks
to cut the movie
so it was important that i at least gave
him something to work with
um and that was that was kind of our
launch pad
and he really you know he
smoothed out the the sort of transitions
between
documentary and narrative i mean it's a
spectrum and there's scenes sort of all
along the spectrum you know with varying
degrees of reality
um but he made that more seamless that
was
really the major contribution he made
and the film wouldn't have
worked if he hadn't tirelessly done that
so i'm very grateful to him
yeah you know i've heard that from other
filmmakers that that rough cut it can be
really a sad day for them you know let's
just be honest
the first draft of the script sucks the
first edit of the film sucks
it's okay except that it sucks and just
keep going i've learned not to get too
down you know nothing is that great
the first time out unless it's a miracle
it's usually by about
draft 10 that it's good for me anyway
maybe i'm a bit slow on the uptake but
i've just learned to accept that
making kind of bad stuff is part of the
process and being able to persevere and
push on
is part of your skill set as a filmmaker
and not to get super bummed
out about it but just say okay this
isn't great the next draft will be
better the next one will be better
the next one will be worse and then the
next one will be way better right it's
just it's a process
so i really accept that yeah
in finding distribution for use me are
there distributors that are squeamish
about the
the topic of the content or no that
hasn't been europe well you know so far
we are getting some great bites and
interest and actually i think
sex sells hey that's not a new idea um
you know i think there will be but i
think that um
people have to get their heads around
what this film is yes it's sexy yes it's
controversial
but at the end of the day it's a really
emotional
story and it is kind of a character
study
so that's kind of tough to for people to
hold that in their minds they sort of
want to make it oh it's just a salacious
sexy
movie and kind of disregard it um but so
far the
critical reviews have been really really
helpful for us
and not in an ego sense at all but when
you don't have stars
critical reviews are like your biggest
asset and we've been blessed with really
positive reviews so far
and that's helping us shape the
conversation and say actually there's a
movie here for a mainstream audience
don't be fooled just by the sexy veneer
of it you know there's a real
story here there's real emotion and real
character-based storytelling so
that's really helping us define what it
is for distributors but mostly they like
the sex mostly they think it's a good
thing
yeah so i'll just ask the question that
i'm sure is already going to be asked or
maybe
it hasn't but the whole exploitation
angle and do you feel like
that's part of what a documentarian has
to be careful of
that you're not sort of exploiting a
subject and
talk about some of the backlash that
could come or maybe it won't come well
firstly people are entitled to have
their own opinion i mean i'm very sex
positive
i'm very much of the view that as long
as there's consent
and clearly defined boundaries i'm not
going to judge you for whatever turns
you on
i recognize that in sierra's line of
work there
is the potential for people to be
exploited now i'm not saying that's what
i've seen happen
but some of these extreme fetishes
it gets a little blurry especially
financial domination or blackmail role
play so
everything i've seen to do is totally
ethical but i respect that people
will have a range of opinions on that
and frankly that's part of what the film
serves up
and and lets the audience make up their
own mind about that
so there's that and then there's just
the exploitation aspect of
okay i'm so i'm this director going into
this world am i exploiting the world
very fair question you know i feel
confident that this is a collaboration i
mean sierra
is an executive producer on the film
when you see it it's clear that we're
equally creative counterpoints um
you know she's been consulted every step
of the way she's watched every cut of
the movie you know we wrote that into
her contract so
we you know protected her right to give
feedback
i've got final cut because i'm the
director and that's not negotiable
however
if you have any problem along the way or
if you feel you're being misrepresented
whether it's documentary or fiction
doesn't matter tell us and we'll listen
so we had a super honest transparent
you know partnership from the beginning
and and there really have been no issues
that way again communication is
everything the door's open to
communicate so we just we just kept
talking every step of the way
but you know yeah this is a film about
the male gaze
and it's about how a woman uses the male
gaze that's how she's made a fortune
so it's super interesting right because
it's kind of like
how she markets herself to men and how
she
uses men i i i i it's it's weird and
then there's my perspective on it it's
all it's all
man what can you say it's uh it's a lot
of blurry lines
isn't it well and the exploitation uh
topic
come up regardless of the subject i just
happen to go there just because
i know i've heard other people say that
about similar films
but it could be about a family that's
doing nothing out of the ordinary but
just living their lives and are you
exploiting them
by showing either a loosely based
narrative of their lives or whatever so
yeah just that that exploitation
question
you know yeah it's going to come up and
you know frankly while i was making the
film the me too
movement happened which is obviously a
fantastic thing but people were like
are you a little bit nervous making a
movie dealing with sexuality in this
climate and
my answer was if you can't make that now
when can you i mean this is this is the
time to talk about
all those things and flush it all out
and have those uncomfortable
conversations and you know i think we
have approached the subject matter in a
tasteful way
in a thoughtful way i can tell you a lot
of thought has been put into it
it's not just my perspective it's a
range of perspectives that have been
funneled into this story so
we hope that the film will inspire
discussion
lively debate conversation in fact
that's why i make
movies and if it's a little
controversial all the better
and it seems like we've gotten to a
point where we can't talk about anything
without
offending some group yeah well look my
thing with that is you know honestly
i've pulled back a bit from
twitter um not that i am like spouting
off controversial opinions but
it's it's more just like pick your
platform
like if i'm gonna be sharing my ideas on
addiction
or male sexuality or
you know sex in the internet age or the
american dream maybe i should do that in
a 90-minute movie
where people can like sit in a theater
and watch it and they've got time to
digest it and ask
questions maybe better to explore it
there than like
a tweet do you know what i mean it's
like pick the right platform
and if you're gonna delve into some
controversial topics make sure it's a
format where there's enough time that
you can deal with it with
nuance i mean frankly i don't really
want to
tweet about some of the topics in this
film it's not appropriate
i can't get my opinion down to 140
characters or whatever it was
that's why we make movies because
there's more to say
right so you know pick your platform um
it's definitely dangerous just airing
every thought that comes into your head
on instagram or
or or twitter and you know um this is
why people get a little bit bland
on social media especially actors you
know of course we're going to be image
conscious
you don't want to put forward a
political opinion or a strong opinion
and
alienate half your fan base immediately
that's kind of where i'm at
you know i'm all for tackling the
thorniest
craziest issues in my movies and i want
to do that and people
frankly want me to do that and they like
that i do that
what's the benefit for me doing that on
instagram or twitter i don't see a lot
you know so my social media is more
about
sharing professional news sharing my
love
sharing my passions my hobbies and it's
all me but
i i do honestly i shy away from that
kind of complexity on social media i
don't really think it's the the right
place for it
what's your advice to directors who are
working with non-actors
find a language that works so in this
film
um you know i had some very seasoned
actors jazlyn yoda
joe reitman who's terrific he's in uh
happy the sci-fi show he's in the
punisher the marvel show he's done a
bunch of movies with kevin smith this
guy's been working for 30 years
so i can hand him a script and it's
going to come out natural
i couldn't do that with sierra no
disrespect to her she gives the most
phenomenal performance in this movie and
critics have rightly pointed that out
but she's not a trained actor
so i couldn't direct her in the same way
so you need to spend a lot of time in
pre-production
figuring out how do you elicit a
naturalistic performance
and my advice would be write your script
know what you want to get out of the
scene but maybe don't show that to them
maybe tell the the person here's what
you want out of the scene
here's what you're trying to get from
the other character so make sure you get
that from them
you know maybe you're trying to get them
to tell you the truth about something so
the scene doesn't end until you've got
them
to tell you the truth so you arm them
with that and then maybe even you feed
them some of the lines of dialogue
you've written
you might say well maybe maybe you could
try it this way maybe would this be
something you'd say
you know maybe so kind of lead them
along but but don't get them into the
the
you know it's just it's a skill set you
have to practice of memorizing lines and
making them natural
so if you realize someone can't do that
turn it into a game
make it feel like improv but arm them
with some of the dialogue they can use
that's kind of what i did on
on use me and you know frankly i think
sierra's performance speaks for itself
she just hit it out of the ballpark
and she is a natural-born performer she
really is
and she's had practice of acting oh yeah
oh no no disrespect she's an actor i
mean she's done 2 000 fetish clips i
mean that's a form of acting
um but yeah she's she didn't go to drama
school
she's not reading pilot scripts and
doing pilot season yeah she's not that
kind of actor
right so just find the sweet spot and um
it's a challenge but it can be worth it
and you know that was the thing like
when i
kind of discovered her online i just
felt she had an x factor and a charisma
and i wanted to show that to the world
and i knew i could
harness it so if you found someone and
you really feel they have that x factor
even if they're not a classically
trained actor or whatever
trust your gut so far it's worked for me
you know when i really get that good
feeling about someone okay they could do
this they're a performer
trust that because sometimes you get
electrifying work from people who are
quote unquote non-actors
i mentioned earlier purpose driven and
then david
interjected off-camera intuitive
confidence
and i actually like that better i think
i could see that in you too
where does that come from well it's
undeniable you get a feeling in your
stomach
and it you can't sleep you're so
electrified
your nervous system is just lit up and
you know that you're going to make a
film
about this idea you've had it's happened
to me three times in my life and each
time it did turn into a
film the first time i saw peter durkase
this
famous south african political satirist
i saw him at the sydney opera house
and he was talking about how he'd gone
all over south africa and he'd seen a
million
school kids educating them about hiv and
aids
and i just put myself in their shoes
these kids that were my age at the time
and it was just like i have to tell the
story i have to go to south africa
i have to make a film about this person
it was undeniable
and that turned into darling the peter
durkee story it happened with cuppa
dreams my second film
and again with sierra i mean i'm not
like exaggerating this or making this
into a story for you when i went on her
website
i knew i was gonna make a movie about
her i
didn't know what it was i had no idea
but i just got
this feeling and believe me i've had a
lot of ideas along the way that never
turned into anything i've had a lot of
scripts that
weren't quite good enough to get made
but if you really get that gut feeling
you owe it to yourself to follow it and
and as time goes on i'm more and more
tuned into that feeling rather than
rationalizing it intellectualizing it
just like does this hit me on a gut
level
yeah and that gives me confidence
because i feel it in the pit of my
stomach
and then i can convey that to other
people and get them to join me
on the journey and help me do it yeah
what about when people try to talk you
out of your experience
because for people that are i mean
everybody's intuitive everyone but some
people have like a higher level
whether it's just from meditation or
yoga or whatever then and then there's
people that
kind of talk you out of your experience
and say oh no you're just being whatever
or i don't know if this will work no for
sure and look at the end of the day it
just it either happens or it doesn't
i mean you know you go into it with full
confidence
and people will either respond
or they won't so maybe i'm a little bit
uh fatalistic isn't the right word
but you just keep making the effort you
keep trying and if it is a good enough
idea
it will get made if it does resonate
with people it will happen
and if it doesn't then sadly it just it
won't happen it'll be too hard
um but at the end of the day it is all
on you when you're the like writer
director you're the one driving it
for years so you need to feel strong
enough that you've got that energy which
lasts
years to keep pushing it along and if
you look inside
and you feel like the energy maybe isn't
there you need to ask yourself is that a
story
i really want to tell for any of your
three
films was there ever a point where you
almost gave up absolutely my second film
cup of dreams was a total
nightmare really proud of the film um
super personal film
it's about new zealanders obsession with
rugby uh it's a bit like canadians and
hockey or brazilians and soccer it's a
national obsession
when the new zealand rugby team like
loses in a world cup
the economy takes a fall people go into
therapy
right wow it is the psyche of the
country is connected to how this team
does
luckily they're a really good team but
um i was an all black fan because i grew
up in new zealand so i love these guys
but i was too close to it i actually
loved rugby too much
and i started making not a very good
film
right and it just ran out of steam the
funding dried up
and i was depressed and i was like okay
i just spent all my savings trying to
make this documentary
i'm broke in fact i'm in debt i got no
idea what's next
and then my producer jonathan green he
kind of picked me up
but he gave me some tough love and he
kind of said look the reason it didn't
work
out is because you're too close you love
this topic
too much you need some objectivity
and so then he helped me step back
realize why do i really love rugby
oh it's actually these personal reasons
and it's about my relationship with my
father
and he helped me delve deeper
and that turned it into a film that
wasn't about sport it became a film
about people and relationships and
home and it connected with an audience
who may have never heard of rugby but
they got it
so i would say sometimes you need a
little bit of distance from your
subjects
right it's good to be passionate but if
if you
are so in love with it that you can't
see the woods for the trees that's not
necessarily a good thing
so sometimes you need people around you
to give you objectivity and use that
because it will help you and it will
help you find the story you really want
to tell
what did you learn from the writing
process for use me
well i i think you know the first
treatment wasn't that
great and it was because there was a
fundamental problem
which was we were trying to send the
wrong character
on an ark right i was trying to send the
sierra character on a certain arc
and it didn't ring true to reality
so i don't want to give spoilers away
for when people see the film but
sometimes when you're hitting your head
against a brick wall when you're writing
it's actually this fundamental problem
of having the wrong protagonist
right the person who you're making
change and transform
it's feeling artificial because that's
just it's just not right for the story
so that really changed from the first
draft of the script where it was very
much about sierra
changing and it just didn't feel
authentic so then i sat down with sierra
and i said all right listen
who do you want to be in this movie do
you want to be bruce wayne or do you
want to be the joker
she said what are we talking about i
said well i'm trying to make this story
where you have this big epiphany and you
change and stuff like that and it kind
of feels
phony maybe your character
doesn't necessarily change fundamentally
maybe how we perceive your character
completely changes but maybe you're just
you
kind of like the joker right this
anarchist who
is kind of the same from beginning to
end and she was like okay
i want to be the joker and i was like i
bet you do so
once we kind of shifted gears and
actually
made my character more the protagonist
meaning you know the conduit through
which
the audience experiences this world
everything changed and the scripts got
much better the whole thing made more
sense
and it all felt more authentic so yeah
the first draft just had a fundamental
problem it was like the wrong
protagonist yeah and is that are those
notes too that your producer had given
you or you came up with that on your own
for sure no i mean it sort of became
apparent to all of us
sierra jonathan green the producer and
myself we just felt this direction isn't
working and it was it was it was obvious
you know that something wasn't right so
we were very
frank about that uh yeah and then we
kind of went in a new direction
and um it felt a lot more authentic
but i wouldn't have got there if i
hadn't written out a conventional
screenplay
so even though the film ended up going
in unexpected directions
it was that foundation of the screenplay
that allowed us
to to move and actually be nimble
like for instance we did a real
kickstarter
campaign okay and someone reached out
and said
i'd give you a lot of money if i could
see a video of you and julian making out
they reached out to sierra
they were like if i could see a video of
you guys making out and teasing me
i'd give you 7 500 wow okay
so that inspired a whole new storyline
which you'll see when you watch the film
but uh yeah you know we were uh
we were able to to be pretty flexible
with the story
also because i was
the lead in it so i had access to myself
all the time i mean i was still
rewriting it in the edit suite
there were video diaries in the film
that i actually shot in the edit suite
so the methodology we employed was
really only possible because sierra and
i were the
leads and we had access to ourselves all
the time
so that's really interesting so if you
see that you're writing a character that
you really can't implement any kind of
arc
maybe that's not the protagonist maybe
they're not meant to change
wow okay very interesting because you
always do want a character to go
on some kind of transformational arc
that's why we love storytelling
that's the lessons that we get from
movies and books
but maybe you've picked the wrong
character maybe that character isn't
meant to change and maybe that's okay
that that's a piece of advice i wish i
could have given myself at the start of
the writing process
but you knew that the character of
julian could change
well it opened up a whole bunch of new
possibilities for the journey my
character could go on just by shifting
the focus
a little bit wow yeah very interesting
yeah
how long was the screenwriting process i
mean you know honestly probably six to
months of writing and really exploring
the material
yeah i mean it's funny you know the film
seems to just kind of like naturally
unfold like it's
it all just really happened but um
right from the first scene it's actually
pretty meticulous how it's all
set up and i hope that's invisible i
hope the audience just feels like it's
spontaneous and it's kind of like this
documentary that kind of
got out of control but um no we really
we plotted it pretty carefully and it's
funny i've never felt so in control of a
process creatively even though it feels
like total chaos while you're watching
it
it was actually the most i've ever felt
like i really had a strong
grip on it so yeah it's sort of an
illusion
the chaos of the movie a very calculated
so do you want to be bruce wayne do you
want to be the joker
it's a good question it depends on the
movie i'm maybe more than bruce wayne in
this movie sierra lynch is a good joker
i'll let her be the joker
your intuition is very powerful for you
your gut check
so you have this intuition about this
film which was ruined me at that time
to use me and then you are several
months into it
you're trying to write the screenplay
but you're struggling
how was that for you because you know
yourself so well that you know that
you trust what you feel what you're
directed toward
it was terrible it was terrible um it's
just part of the process you have to go
down
detours and how do you get through that
i mean honestly you just grit your teeth
and keep going and try to believe in
that original
inspiration that you had because when
you first get the idea for a movie it's
like
super clear it's like i don't want to
say hd or 4k i'm going to say
8k clarity and then you have to turn
into a screen player then you have to
actually start filming it
and then it gets blurry like you know
1980s analog
tv and you're like where's my 8k clarity
it was so clear when i had the idea
and honestly that's just the process you
just have to commit to it except it's
going to suck for a while
and believe that you're going to come
back to that original pure idea that got
you so excited
i also really believe you have to
explore
bad ideas to get to the to get to the to
the good one so
you need to reframe it as okay you know
what i went down a path that just didn't
work creatively
great i'm making progress i can put that
aside
that's not what this film's going to be
now that i know that
i'm getting closer to the ideas that are
going to work
so a lot of it is this kind of crazy
sounding positive
self-talk but if i'm being honest that's
that's the kind of stuff that keeps me
going because it's hard it's hard when
it's not working
you know and pretty much give yourself
time
keep pushing and have faith in that
original idea if it was strong enough to
make you feel something
you know that there's some nugget of
gold and you just you got to get to it
through perseverance
well it reminds me too of how you went
to film school after you'd made
a movie or two and it's that's so
interesting because most people it's the
opposite
right and and then they're either jaded
or they love it but you
use it as inspiration yeah and you know
i mean look everyone's different so i
don't want to recommend any anything
oh sure but for me i needed to go and
make stuff
on my own outside of any system i needed
to
to take risks fail succeed on my own
find my own voice
i got to a point where i just couldn't
keep doing that and i was burned out and
that was where film school
came in and i really studied okay what
is
hollywood screenwriting what is the
hero's journey you know all these really
fundamental things
that was instrumental for me and i've
just made a movie that's kind of edgy
and
and breaks the rules somewhat i could
break them because i
learned all the rules you know i know
how to write a
three-act structure you know i did the
wonderful michael hague course i've seen
him on your show
all that stuff is brilliant and if you
do want to make like avant-garde edgy
movies
learn the fundamentals of of you know
what you'd call like studio hollywood
storytelling
learn those beats inside out then you
really can
break the rules one other thing i will
say
film school is such a luxury and i went
into it with a funny attitude
i went into it like i want to make my
worst stuff here
now i don't mean that i set out to do an
unprofessional job
i wanted it to be as good as it could be
but i pushed myself i made stuff that i
hadn't tried to make before because
there was a safety net
i was at film school if i made something
truly horrendous
i could make it go away and it would
never see the light of day it's not like
it's going to be a commercially released
film and my reputations on the line
so film school for me was great i tried
a bunch of different things
i realized there are certain things i
kind of suck at and i kind of found my
voice
through that process so really i i had a
lot of failures
at film school and because i kind of got
those out of my system in a safe
environment
my work got a lot better after i
graduated and i think that's why film
school is actually good for people
it's not that they give you some magic
secret sauce
you can learn a lot online you can plug
you can learn a lot from watching film
courage
truly you can you could probably learn
everything they could teach you but
there's something about that process and
failing in a safe environment
figuring out who you are just giving
yourself a year or two to walk on the
tightrope knowing there's a safety net
there
that can be huge so that's why i would
encourage people to go to film school
give yourself that luxury to fail with a
safety net it really
it's worked for me yeah i mean it's
great that there's all these online
classes and stuff but there's really
something about being
around other people even if it's just
watching what they're doing
100 i mean it's not just about what they
teach you it's the cohort
you know and i have collaborated with
the directors who are in my class
you know i've acted a couple times for
casey anning who's an incredible
australian director who's really going
places
uh stephen mccallum who just made his
first feature one percent
uh i think it's called outlaws in
america uh they've become good friends
and and collaborators and
you know they like encouraged me to get
back into acting
they were so adamant about and they cast
me as an actor and that really
kind of kick-started my acting career
again and then while i've been working
on you know directing and developing the
script it's like you know i went into
uh san andreas and got to work with paul
giamatti i went into port landy i've
been shooting tv commercials in portland
so it's kind of like i really
credit film school with leading me back
to acting in a funny way so
yeah are you able to describe your
process
either with writing or being on set i do
a lot of my thinking late at night i
have terrible insomnia so i'm not going
to advocate having this
set routine and you know get up and
start writing at 7am and do it till 12pm
but just be consistent time is the magic
ingredient
we were lucky on use me that we could
sort of employ a documentary methodology
and take a bit longer
and write and shoot and edit and then
kind of see how it was working
and i would advocate doing that
give yourself time if you don't have
money give yourself time
it really is the magic ingredient and
without film
uh because it was privately financed we
didn't have sort of a distributor or
studio breathing down our necks
we took a bit longer and the film got
better and we even did things like uh we
did audience testing through a company
called
indie i-n-d-e-e oh interesting five
thousand dollars
brutally honest you get hundreds of
people giving you their feedback on the
movie
and it was great you know we made some
tweaks based on that
uh we also were heartened because we got
good numbers we actually got a positive
response so we felt okay this is good
but i would say build all those things
into your process
build feedback into your process give
your ideas
lots of air don't you know
like gollum my precious don't do that
you know with trusted people i'm not
saying with everyone but
share your ideas give them oxygen give
yourself time
it will make your film better i promise
so what were some just a couple notes
from this indie
audience testing that's really
interesting um
well well firstly we were encouraged
because you know people
loved the interplay of the
reality and fiction and they were
intrigued by that but moreover they just
liked the story
and they actually kind of stopped caring
about how real things were
or weren't they were just invested in
the characters so that was a big win for
us
and that's been reflected by a few
people like my executive producer mark
lazarus
he thought the whole thing was fiction
he didn't know sierra lynch was a real
person he just was a movie
and then he found out oh it's kind of
like real life
he didn't care he just liked the story
so that's kind of what we've been hoping
for
we found out a couple of scenes didn't
necessarily work
um found out that you know my
performance in one scene probably wasn't
where it should be so we'd have an
honest conversation about that
re-shot the scene ended up being really
strong we had the luxury of doing that
um so there were a couple little
little beats that we changed yeah based
on that feedback
i'm really glad we did it gave us a lot
of confidence
you know trying to think what else
you know it also just kind of made us
think
who is the audience for this because we
thought oh well it's going to be
men and we might have a problem with
women you know just
given the subject matter no our female
numbers were
amazing i mean they were as good as the
male numbers
pretty much across the board i mean it
definitely skews a little bit older male
but the the older female numbers were
right there with them so that was super
encouraging
so you know and you do need to think
about that it's not just
creative and i'm an artist telling my
story you've always got to think okay
well who is going to watch this film
in the end so any information you can
get on who the story is appealing to or
who the characters are appealing to
that's very useful as a filmmaker
what would you tell to 20 year old
directors just getting started
or they don't have to be 20 they could
be younger i got it
start making stuff you have an iphone
in your pocket it's perfectly good just
start practicing your craft
but figure out what really turns you on
you know and just be yourself maybe you
do things in an unconventional way
and some people might think that's a
weakness but actually
that can become a strength like i
realized at film school
certain kinds of movies that i love to
watch
i wasn't very good at making you know
just because i love paul thomas anderson
doesn't mean i could make a film
like him you know you can get really
enamored with these giants of
hollywood um and think well i've got to
make something like my hero
and then i kind of realized well
actually the weirder things about my
sensibility
that i used to think were a weakness are
my strength
that's what makes me original that's my
voice and the stronger and more unique
your voices actually the more commercial
your work will be right
because it's pure and it touches people
so
just try and find your voice and you can
do that for no money you can do that
with your iphone
just keep making things keep pushing and
you will get there
you will get that i find that
interesting so yeah just because you
love
certain style don't try to emulate it
because it may not be
kind of you know like we all go through
a thing where we fall in love with
hitchcock or
whoever oscar says he these incredible
people and then you look at what you're
making and you can be so dispirited
because of course it's not as good as
hitchcock or
scorsese um and realistically it
probably never will be but
that's okay don't try and be them try
and be
you and i probably intellectually knew
that
but as time has gone on i really feel
i feel that in my stomach that i've just
got to be me and actually my
unique weird whatever take on things
is good enough and actually it's a lot
better than if i'm trying to copy
filmmakers
that i admire but that just comes with
experience
you know so looking back on everything
now
why are you still working in the film
industry
i just i mean i just love it i don't
know what else to tell you it's a cliche
but it just
it lights me up it's there's nothing
that satisfies me more
and you know i just showed the film in
brooklyn like a couple of days ago
and hearing the audience gasp in shock
or
laugh or you know have whatever
emotional reaction they
had it really does make it all
worthwhile because
you do this because you're trying to
connect with others i mean that's the
word that underscores this all
weirdly you go into a very isolated
space and you're working on it for a few
years and you're
in an edit room or you're writing and a
lot of moments of being
alone and isolated but it's that
communal atmosphere that you're always
thinking about
and how is this going to play for an
audience and when you get the joy of
that happening and it works
it really makes all the ups and downs
worthwhile
and that's why i do it you know because
that's what inspired me when filmmakers
gave me that good feeling of joy in my
heart
and i hope to be able to keep doing that
for the rest of my life it's the only
thing i want to do whenever i go into a
movie theater and there's no one there
i'm like i hope
at least one person i don't want to be
the only one here even if it's just one
person and it doesn't have to be a movie
theater it could be somebody watching it
on a streaming
platform but you know if if you can get
across that thing that was in your head
to that person that's cool it's super
hard
but the challenge is part of what makes
it worthwhile
so i don't know what to tell you i just
irrationally totally
love it with all my heart despite how
hard it is maybe because of how hard it
is
and i think i'll keep doing it till the
day i die
what are the stories you want to tell
and be involved in
well you know honestly i just want to
entertain people i just want people to
walk out of films that i'm acting in or
directing feeling like they're walking
on air maybe i've taken them to a really
dark place
but that they feel more alive by the end
of it
um so actually you know i just want to
give people
joy i think that's really what it's all
about for me
um and if you can inspire
you know discussion about tough issues
or
controversial issues or or maybe issues
that are quite unresolved in society
that's great but number one
entertain people you know and even if
that's all you do
that's enough that's really enough to
give people joy is
is a pretty amazing thing so i want to
be a part of productions that do that
did you see the room i did see the room
i saw the room in portland with tommy
wiseau oh you did
and you know what how fun it's kind of a
masterpiece uh-huh i mean okay is it a
zero-star movie or a five-star movie
well you could argue that it's a
five-star movie i mean because of the
audience engagement and the joy
if that's your pure metric it's one of
the best movies i've ever seen
and people throwing right at the screen
and
right i mean you know and again like i
said professional wrestling people think
that's very
uncool um but it brings tears to my eyes
it gives me
joy that's awesome you know that's
that's
you feel alive when you when you got
that smile on your face
yeah that's really cool
he was in the audience he came and did a
q a
it was so cool it was really great
why do you ask about that i was just
thinking of the one seen
in the um the one with james franco
where
just you see him pull up in a limo you
know and it's
it's just that that night of like the
first screening for all filmmakers
yeah and there's so many emotions but
it's like this
stamp of okay i did it right and now
people are coming to see it
and sometimes it's a bigger deal than it
really is and sometimes it's the
opposite
totally but you don't know that going
into it totally
and so that scene and then he drives
around again you know it's and it's
funny
and especially if you've ever had your
first screening and you just kind of
know
how like it's such a huge deal but that
is anxious as hell i mean
right you can't not be right right so
yeah i don't know why i just that popped
into my head when you were talking and i
just pictured tommy why so
the real tommy why so in the limo or no
sorry the james franco
version yeah in the limo um going around
the only thing i could really add is
like you never quite know what's going
to connect with people i'm not sure if i
even have an answer
to say about this but it's like you just
kind of keep making stuff and it can
surprise you what does
hit it might not be the thing that you
expect but if you just keep making stuff
i don't really have a formal answer it's
just something i've noticed you know
right
yeah anyway you know
i'm not sure what i would say about it
like you never know how an audience is
going to respond but you just have to be
connected to
keeping on telling stories and then
eventually if you do it there'll be
something that sort of seems to land
right maybe that's why there's no
answers because we never know i mean to
have this viral video
right oh that totally fell into my lap
and then it's like okay
wow that opened all these doors and yeah
sure yeah you just don't know
but if you keep making the effort and
putting yourself out there it's more
likely you're gonna find
something that will connect you know
that's really all you can control
did tommy do a q a he did he did
anything interesting he said oh my god
well he was loving the whole thing and i
just realized it's a pretty good
business model i mean he's selling
t-shirts and uh selling posters and i
was like this guy's really this is a
profitable movie now
this is a super profitable movie so he
kind of owns it he was playing a
character
right i mean he's playing tommy but he's
very smart for doing that
right and he does it well yeah it was
cool
i really enjoyed that and the disaster
artist was a really good movie too
i thought it was very funny but then
there's also parts that are very true
to anybody who's ever trying to make a
film completely frighteningly true
you